Shiran Elizur, thank you so much
for being on my show.
How are you?
I'm well. How are you?
Fantastic.
Thank you so much
for being so generous with your time.
And I know you have your daughters at home
and you're out of the office,
and I truly truly appreciate it.
I have so much to learn from you
with your experience
in all of different companies.
But most recently now in Super-Pharm,
running their brand development
and thinking of the next brands
that the customers want, right?
Right.
Incredible. Okay.
So, for those that are perhaps
in California, not in Tel Aviv right now,
Super-Pharm is one of Israel's
largest pharmacy chain.
It's like the regular CVS and Walgreens
that we have here,
where you go in
and you have both Super-Pharm items,
but you also have an abundance
of other brands in the store
that it's like a go-to place.
So, Shiran, before we dive
into Super-Pharm and your work there,
give me a little bit of background
into who you are and the journey
that you've gone through
to get to the world that you have today.
I actually stumbled upon it by chance.
I was living in New York
doing my masters at the new school,
and I was looking for an internship.
Which internships,
if it's not like Google or Microsoft,
they are not very big in Israel.
So when I went to the IDC,
I was just a waitress.
Work to make a living and to pay the rent.
But when I moved to New York,
it was obviously a great,
amazing opportunity
to be a part of great companies.
So, I actually was working
in the hospitality industry like events
and clubs, basically.
Someone who knew someone in Revlon
got me an interview.
I was accepted.
I was a master's student
along with lots of like college girls.
But still, it turned out quite okay
because I stayed there for a while after.
So, I was a part
of the product development team.
By the way, was that a turn off
or was that difficult to go into
a US based internship
where a lot of people there
are college students
that are much younger than you?
No, I didn't mind. So, first of all,
I was quite young. I mean, I was only 25.
It's not like I was like
in my 30s or something.
And I didn't really mind
because they were all a part
of the PR team and I was
in the product development team.
So, I have a different position
and different things to do.
Later then, I actually joined
this PR team as, just to work there
for a few months as well,
and then I move to another company.
So actually, I mean, I always love brands.
Also, food wise and in general,
I always found it interesting
also as a little girl.
What is a brand?
Give me your insight
into a two minute lecture.
What constitutes a brand
in the 21st century?
I feel like it's mostly an emotion.
Or something that
makes you feel something.
For me, not because I work there,
but Super-Pharm is the strongest brand
for me as being a woman.
Being in my 30s, being a mother.
And it was always a feeling for me,
even back when I was 16,
back when I was a soldier.
Because this retailer, this chain,
like their logo and everything,
walks with you through your life.
But I can also think of brands,
obviously like Glossier,
that make you feel special.
That are making you feel unique.
And they have to do
with how you feel about yourself,
how you position yourself.
So, I think they are,
first of all, emotions.
And second, they are tools
to identify and differentiate yourself
in society, among other people,
especially today.
Especially when talking to gen setters.
It's all about
how you differentiate yourself.
What does using or purchasing
or wearing the brand tells about you.
What does it say when you post
on your Instagram
that you shot something
or did you support your brand
or are you disappointed.
Right. Right.
So, It's mostly about self Identification,
differentiation for yourself
as the persona and emotion.
I love it. Okay.
So, let's transition now
to what you're doing today.
So, you have your experience at Revlon.
And you've also had experience
within a packaging company,
that distributes beauty products.
Right. They make package development
like they work with everyone,
with the entire L'Oreal group,
with Estee Lauder Group,
with Chanel, now she said with everyone.
And I learned a lot there
working with Mac and with Bobby Brown
and with all the big names.
Obviously, again,
I was a writer after school.
So I took whatever they gave me.
And it started with
running errands for everyone
and sitting in the messenger center
with everyone.
And I did it with much love
and dedication.
And it taught me a lot.
But then I decided, along with my husband,
to come back here to Israel
because we wanted to start a family.
In New York, obviously,
it's not even relevant money wise.
So, we came back here
and I worked for four years
in April cosmetics,
which is like a specialty beauty.
It's more like
on the selective higher end tier.
A bit more than two and a half years ago,
I moved to Super-Pharm,
which was like a dream come true for me.
Super-Pharm for me, it's for retail.
It's like it's Google. Really.
Yeah. Yeah.
So, just give me the context a little bit
into the Israeli ecosystem
and where is Super-Pharm
is located within that.
Because I think it's important
for the remainder of the conversation
to understand the incredible work
you're doing within Super-Pharm.
To understand how big Super-Pharm is
and how it integrates
into the lives of every Israeli.
But it's actually not just Israelis,
but it's also abroad.
Right.
First of all, Israel is a tiny country.
It's only nine million people.
And Super-Pharm has 260 doors.
So, it's literally everywhere.
It's a 10-minute drive
from every Israelis house, basically.
Every Israelis house.
Yeah, it's in the radius of everyone's,
it's in neighborhoods, in malls.
And it's everywhere.
It's the leading and larges
health and beauty retailer
here in Israel.
Its private label is huge.
And because we have those capabilities,
manufacturing, shipping,
logistic capabilities,
we decided two and a half years ago
to also operate as a distributor.
So, we also work directly with brands,
not manufacturers,
that create the life brand
for our private label, but retailer brands
that we negotiate with
and then decide to launch them directly
without a middleman.
Without a distributor in the middle.
We operate both as a retailer
and distributor for them.
And this is, we only we carry brands
that we feel and we know
that the Israeli customer is looking for.
Okay. Shiran, what is the Israeli customer
is looking for?
This sounds like such a difficult question
that you're sitting and you have to,
you're looking at a product
and you're saying,
"Hey, can I imagine a million people
buying this?"
"Yes or no?"
It sounds so,
I'm coming in as an engineer
from a very scientific background,
and I need everything
to be quantifiable in numbers.
But you can never quantify
something like this, right?
First of all, we, I mean,
Israeli customers, especially women,
are extremely online savvy.
So, we have this data.
We can look for it.
We know we have online competition.
We see which brands
they follow on Instagram.
they discuss on Facebook groups.
We ask questions.
We have our teams in 260 doors
telling us which brands
they're asking to purchase, to buy.
So, we have a decent clue.
But on the other hand,
we're looking for newness.
We're looking for innovation,
which is a bit, it's a different term
when we're talking about
skin care or beauty.
Because it's quite challenging
to create newness in these fields.
So, basically I would not launch a brand
that no one here knows.
Because I would not want
to waste time or money
on market education.
I rather have brands
that people already
purchase online from abroad,
or big names that everyone know.
And if it's a new brand,
I'd rather develop a brand myself.
If it's an unknown brand,
I'd rather create a brand of my own
like we did already
with three different ones.
And then you educate the market,
but you have a higher GP.
You have the ability
to control the materials
to create them from scratch.
So, I would say for your question,
we're looking for brands
that are very Instagram oriented, again,
because Instagram is a key factor
in my decision making process.
And we're looking for brands, obviously,
with good quality.
Not necessarily expensive.
Like the customers here
are very price savvy.
And for me, it's an agenda.
We only launch brands
that allow us to offer the products
for the same price as country of origin.
Like if I'm launching a UK brand,
price would be the same
if a customer would buy it
when she visits London.
Or if it's an American brand,
same thing.
And we always have competition.
Like I buy my beauty products on ASOS
and I have a discount code.
It's aisle 17,
to every Israeli girl here
knows it.
So, we always have competition.
And sometimes,
you can buy the products
for a lower price.
But still it's, I feel it's decent.
And we were being honest and decent
and we offer the goods in a good price.
So, it's both pricing and portfolio,
like choices that we need to make.
So, it sounds like
you have an awesome playground.
Because you have an idea for a new brand
that you want to develop,
you might get an idea
from some competition you say,
"Well, actually, I think I can do better."
"I can do it cheaper with better materials
and with my own branding."
And you mentioned that
you've already gone through this adventure
a few times.
And launching this brand to 260 doors.
First thing, you want to create
a new brand
and you want to test it
to the market,
Shiran, what do you do?
Like walk me through this lifecycle
of bringing this to fruition.
Because it sounds like
what you've got to play around with
sounds like successfully,
is something that a lot of people,
I love watching Shark Tank,
it sounds like that's what
every Shark Tank pitch person does, right?
Thinking of a brand,
and you get to think through it
with the team and launch it already
in 260 stores.
Yeah.
First of all, it's a lot of fun.
Skincare, beauty in general
it is a playground.
But I think you have to have
a professional background.
You know, my husband told me
when we were I think 24,
"Be a professional."
When we were deliberating,
should I take this internship.
He told me, I mean,
if you go for it, this is your path.
Become a professional
in the sense that
this is like the best tip he ever gave me.
And since then, I read all researchers.
I actually share it with people
in my workplace.
Like this is my turf,
beauty, industry, global, trends.
So, I think first of all,
you have to be a professional
at what you do.
Not everyone can create a beauty brand.
Second thing you do, for me anyway,
we were looking for the relevant trends
and we create a mood board.
Like we have our references,
we have tons of data, obviously,
in Super-Pharm.
So, we're looking for the brands
that tell the most.
The specific products
that we're looking for.
It's mostly like a business administration
It's things you learn in school.
But in general,
if I'm thinking marketing wise,
I'm creating a mood board.
I'm talking to a designer.
I choose the right assortment.
You have to be very accurate.
I never develop products
that we already have in our portfolio.
It's always newness.
And mostly, when we work on a brand
or when we choose a brand,
I mostly think about
how does the customer feel.
Like who is my customer
and how does she want to feel
when she purchases a product
of this brand.
How long does this process take
from this idea that you have
for a new cosmetic product,
to when I see it to 260 stores?
Today, you can do it
in four months, five months.
Sometimes, look, we have longer projects.
But I feel like this is a reality today.
If you look at influencers
and a lot of very small niche brands
that are being created from scratch now,
it's not like back then
when processes were way longer.
You can develop with a designer,
with a factory, on Instagram.
You can build the brand quite quickly.
There's registration and formulations.
But if you work with existing formulas
or you just upscale them a bit,
it doesn't take long.
This is the reality now.
People get famous in a second
and then they create their own brands
in a second.
And you go to sleep.
The next day you wake up,
you have three new brands.
Especially in the beauty industry.
So, we have to work fast
because we have competition.
Yeah, so.
So, what is the hardest thing
about this job?
So, is it the ideation phase?
Is it the competition, the analytics
and understanding what's happening?
I think choosing the right assortment.
Making sure the customers are happy.
And I think the most challenging thing
is to, well, obviously,
if you know what you are,
you can make a lot of money.
It's just knowing
what the customer is looking for.
For me working in Super-Pharm,
I mean, I'm a 33 year old mother of three,
so, I am the ideal Super-Pharm customer.
For personal care, for toiletries,
for diapers, for everything.
But for beauty,
there's a whole crowd out there
of 12, 16, 18 year olds.
I'm not them.
And I have to sell them
what you're looking for.
And sometimes they're half my age
or less, and I need to know
what they're looking for.
And this is a big challenge.
This is for me
is the most challenging thing.
Because you don't want to be pathetic.
You don't want to try and fail.
And I'm only 33. It's not like I'm 60.
Right?
But I see my, I have a daughter,
she's five and a half
and she is interested
in specific products.
She and her friends.
So, this maybe an easier age,
but a 16 year old which has money
and she is able to purchase
whatever she wants
and she's willing to spend money,
for me, it's quite challenging.
And I think it's relevant to all
I mean, not even not only the beauty
or toiletries in the streets,
in every industry,
also in fashion, also in general.
Exactly.
I'm coming to Stanford at 24.
And all of my classmates are using TikTok.
I have no idea what this platform is about
and why people would want
to look at 15 second videos.
I'm starting to get it,
but it's a different mentality.
But so, Shiran,
how do you compensate for that?
Because you have the responsibility
of selling to this demographic as well.
And you need to be an expert on it
just as much as you're an expert
on the 33 year old
young mothers in Israel.
So, how do you go and study
what do 16 year olds want
and what the 22 year olds want?
Well, Super-Pharm obviously,
we have a lot of researchers and group.
And we have agencies
that get money for it.
But I rather be ahead of trend.
The pathetic thing is coming in the end.
Because the research
is always in hindsight.
It's not necessarily forecasting, right?
Right. I'm not on Tiktok, obviously.
But I'm trying to identify trends
through style sites citing
and trend forecasting platforms
and through Instagram.
Instagram is like it's the strongest,
most important tool for me.
This is the key to everything.
I always think
if a brand is Instagramable,
now, we also think about it in Tiktok.
But we're trying to find additional ways.
We ask questions.
We notice, if it's an older crowd,
we can also use Facebook groups.
But for the challenging group
of  Gen Z, it's a problem.
I'm telling you the truth.
I have a brand. One of my brands
has a skin care, like a roller,
a rose quartz roller,
which is very big on Instagram.
Well, it was for the last two years.
I recently found out
girls that are ten and eleven
are purchasing this product.
They don't need it. Okay?
But it looks good on camera,
so they buy it.
Wow, that's fascinating.
What is one thing that you learned
about brands that you didn't know
before you joined the Super-Pharm?
What is the one insight you've gained
over the past few years that you look up?
I'm starting to understand
what this whole brand thing is about.
That you can create emotional connection
to a brand quite quickly
if you're accurate.
And that, well, globally, business wise,
I feel like big brands that I was raised on
and all women in globally,
all the women in the world,
that we always looked at Estee Lauder,
Clinique, Lancôme,
basically a lot of French brands.
France was like the empire of beauty.
They got this insulting title
of legacy brands.
And they are starting to look very uncool
to young ladies.
And I learned that
it doesn't really matter
how much money you have,
because, I mean,
you might lose it anyway.
So, it has to do
with making right choices.
Estee Lauder for example, two years ago
they started working with,
or maybe three years ago already,
they took Kendall Jenner
and put her in the front
in order to speak to Gen Z.
It didn't really help, I feel.
Because they use the same products
like a serum, that is nearly 500 shekels,
like $100 or something,
and got her to wear a red suit.
Like, who wears a red suit?
So, it's talking to older women again,
using a younger ambassador.
So, it doesn't really matter
how much money you have.
We have a small niche brands
that support, take and make them explode
because they're accurate and right.
They speak to the customers of tomorrow.
The customers that
they are looking for now.
They already have
the 50, 60 year old women buy there.
They don't necessarily have
the 16 year old's.
Right. Shiran, this was
incredibly insightful.
Thank you for your time and generosity.
And I know you have kids
in the other room.
So, really, thank you
for taking the time to do this.
I really appreciate it.
Before we leave, I need three words
that you would use to describe yourself.
I am impatient.
This is a hard one.
This is the hardest question of all.
Yeah. I don't really have patience.
I think, I listen.
Okay.
Yeah, I listen and pay attention
to comments.
That makes a lot of sense.
Yeah. And I multitask.
I'm a great believer
in done is better than perfect.
Since honestly not sounding like a cliche.
I read Leneen and I took this,
well, it's not her sentence, obviously,
but I took it and this is my way of life.
I'd rather finish most tasks in 90% way
instead of holding back on one specific.
I'm not a perfectionist,
let's just say that.
So, I think two very important tips are
finish what you started.
Even if it's not perfect,
just get it over with
and move to your next task.
And be a professional.
Choose one thing, dive in,
know what you're talking about,
become an expert and that's it.
Shiran, toda raba.
Thank you very very much.
And I can't wait to share this
with the world. Thank you.
Bye.